[Music]
on today's show we talked to two
different moms who are wrestling with
how they can best support their
teenagers
bullying with keeping secrets from dad
and we also talk about this article
facebook and instagram know what they're
doing to our kids and what we can do to
help stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what up
this is john with the dr john delaney
show up so glad you're with us
we talked about mental health
relationships families parenting
james obsession with ponies in unicorn i
don't know some weird thing he likes
dragons and unicorns he's got all these
games he's always playing back in there
kelly's not here but austin is here
full beard
not near as
i'm just gonna stop right there i'm glad
you're here austin
see money over there on the
screens pushing buttons and knobs and
faders it's good to see everybody all
smiling faces
james
listen
i just looked over at you and you're
just wiping your brow and it's like god
i hate my job i'm just thinking about
all the money that kelly's racking up
when you say listen
oh dude man
what were you gonna say
i was gonna say
i've got this incredible article from
the wall street journal
out september 14th
on
what facebook knows about instagram
and
kids so hang tight this
is a good one
and it gives me hemorrhoids
this this if i wish this episode was
brought to you by preparation h it is
not but
when i read this it gave me such gas it
makes me rage i'm working hard on that
sponsorship don't you worry
preparation h for the hemorrhoids i
don't really have hemorrhoids america
and by america i mean all 33 of us
you all know that
well man i just made this all weird now
austin's like dude what show am i what
are we doing i worked hard to get to
this this is i went to college told my
friends hey guys guess what i'm on this
new show i thought i got out of the
medical field
we are back my friend we are back
oh i don't even know where to go from
hemorrhoids let's go to uh marie in
anchorage what's up marie how's it going
good how are you i'm from preparation h2
yes to my question to marie yes and
listen
this is probably one of those moments
when you were like i was going to tell
my friends i was on the show and then
the lead-in is talking about hemorrhoids
and how angry i get at facebook and
instagram so sorry about that so here's
something i'm going to pause
and now you can just cut it and hand it
directly to them from there and that way
you'll miss
the weird stuff where i talk about
my body all right so how's it going
perfect
it's going good um my question is i have
a son that is dealing with bullying at
school and he seems to be super unhappy
and he's kind of a pessimistic
personality he's a twin he's um kind of
always been that way a little bit okay
and i'm not sure as a parent
how do you balance
like i want to i mean they talk to me
more than any other i have three older
kids too that are grown
and these boys talk to me i mean i'm so
blessed but
um
you know hearing what they're saying
it's like i want to validate their
feelings i want to listen i want to take
it seriously but at the same time life
is super hard is it normal stuff that
i'm dealing with do i toughen him up you
know how do i balance all of that
because
he is my baby things are harder for him
than his twin
academically socially it's hard for him
to express himself
and
you know now he's not trying to school
at all
and he's suffering and he's telling me
about it and i just don't know i need
real things to do i need real things
that will help do i take them in and
tried medication we tried it when he was
younger do i take them out of school put
them in a new school
you know do i
i don't know i'm wrong
first
man that's so hard that's heartbreaking
because you love that little boy right
he is amazing
absolutely amazing i hate that for him i
hate that for me talented
um he is musically talented he can drum
like no other
um
he has a comedic humor that is far
beyond his peers so i don't think they
understand him a room full of adults
would be in stitches
but
i just think that he's 14 and he's you
know he things are super like i said
they're super hard for him and he has a
twin brother that everything's easy for
being competitive he not only yeah he
not only has
the acute feelings of people picking on
him and giving him crap or realizing i
got a funny joke here nobody gets how
funny this is or
i'm drumming on stuff and the teacher's
always hollering at him to be still and
quit moving and this and that but he
also has a picture of
himself in another body doing everything
right
right oh they're not identical they
don't look anything alike so that okay
okay so it's just this weird ugly
brother that's fine that's totally
different
um okay so
great questions and really something
that parents all over have been
wrestling with for a long time
do i just like life is hard and we let's
let them get toughened up if i run in
there and rescue them for everything i'm
actually stealing from them
in the future from their future selves
i'm preventing them from learning how to
solve problems how to
how to
get resources etc
and
bullying's changed over the last 20
years there's a there's a
digital component to it cyber bullying
right that these things that
our brains have mechanisms
okay okay
um
kids have gotten mean in a way that
they've always been mean kids have
always been ugly and mean
but it has changed the stuff i dealt
with as a kid was brutal and the stuff i
saw my students deal with for us 20
years is another level it is brutal and
i think
lack of civility from parents
change in entertainment has shifted
there's just everything's just
laid on top of each other and whoa
loss of consequences when i was a kid if
you mouthed off to the wrong guy you got
hit in the mouth there was a natural
consequence and i'm not saying that's
great but it was a leveling effect we
all knew
you do this this could be a result
that's gone now and if you hit somebody
you go to jail and so there's just this
consequence-free environment and there's
just some kids who are just paying the
price for it
so here's here's the litmus test for me
and i will tell you this is hard for me
because i mess this up with my own kid
and i won't go into too much detail but
i didn't do it the right way
um i didn't listen to him and i missed
some things and um i just have to live
with that and i got to forgive myself
and then do better next time and um
which is good but i didn't listen
so the difference is kids say mean stuff
that's life
kids push on each other and get each
other's faces and say things that's
that's life
so there's a difference between kids who
are mean and kids experiencing mean
things or uncomfortable things
and
bullying
so
the definition of bullying is
a couple of things aggressive
repetitive
intentional
and power dynamic
so is your kids constantly drumming in
class on things and the kid next to him
says hey spaz hey maniac quit
right
that's that in my mind is not bullying
see that i try to get to the bottom of
that and when he when we do sometimes
i'm like ah
you know i hate that's like not
not that bad but you're thinking i'm
gonna tell him these things right i want
to tell you that exactly where are you
exactly there you
go or is there a group a guy a kid a
young lady is there a group who seek
your son out
to prop themselves up
that they they seek him out to diminish
him to make fun of him to mock him
and they send him
text messages or snapchats that
reinforce that he's less than that he's
dumb and it's pervasive it goes on and
on and on
so when somebody's mean you can avoid
them you walk away or if somebody does a
thing they snap you and say something
like you're an idiot you're stupid
you're always moving around but that's
annoying it's not bullying
it's the pervasive aggressive repetitive
they are seeking my kid out so that's
number one
number two
is
have you involved
school support network yet
so have you called teacher and said hey
my son is telling me these things what
are you saying
yes and they they were unaware of that
of course they wanted names and i
personally like when i'm talking about
certain kids that do these things i mean
i've known these kids forever and i know
they're parents
and
i like to me it hasn't been bad enough
to say anything because i just i don't
want them to go you know get the wrath
of their parents like you i can't
believe you said that to another child
when they're 14 and they all say really
stupid things all the time like my kids
do it everybody does it
they do but you and i what's just stupid
and roll your eyes and dumb
you and i have 15 or 20 years worth of
wisdom right right and teflon
and our little ones don't and so if you
put yourself in their position as a
parent and if you got a call that said
your son was saying this to some young
little girl in her class some 14 year
old girl in her class
or
to a 14 year old boy in your class
and your blood would boil
make that phone call
yeah
say hey can we
i'm struggling i want my you know we've
known each other for a long time and
have that conversation i would start
with the school
in my situation i did i started with the
school
and i didn't see it clearly enough that
what my son was trying to communicate to
me and we had him in some fancy pants
high fluting
nonsensical private school and now he's
at a public school loving loving loving
life and that's not a statement on
public schools or private schools
i just thought that because it's fancy
it's going to be perfect and it was a
disaster for him
they let him know you don't belong here
both
implicitly and explicitly both the
teachers and the students
and
so i didn't listen i kept trying to
drill down into the instances
but what did this kid say that one time
and what i didn't my ten year old or
nine-year-old or seven-year-old didn't
have was the ability to articulate i
don't belong here man and every time i
go i i
am i'm not okay
and i didn't have that language and so
we stayed another year and we shouldn't
have and then we got them into a new
environment and it made all the
difference
if you think your kid might be on the
spectrum you mentioned that what makes
you think that
um he just is i mean we've had school
testing done i've never
had
i mean i haven't taken him to a bigger
city and done extensive but um he's kind
of a uh enigma like they don't really
he's kind of all over the place he has
like he's he just tests super high in
some things and just way below
proficiency in others
and
he's i mean he's just
i i wish you could meet him
he sounds amazing he sounds incredible
he he is but uh
communicating how he feels and stuff is
not something that's easy when i have a
conversation with him
and i love him to pieces it's super
frustrating i mean it's like i don't my
you know my other son is like
easy for me to talk to and i have one
that's hard and and even though i'm
listening to him
so healing for him i want you to try
this it may not work but i have had some
moms reach out to me and it just happens
to be moms who reached out and said they
won the lottery with this one i want you
to get a notebook that y'all share
and he owes you
either a written response a story about
the day or a picture or a poem or
something every day and you will respond
oh my gosh see this is why i called i
want real
homework so get a it can be if i'm you i
would overpay for something i would go
to the store and get some bound non like
some
highfalutin something or other make it
all kumbaya special
um and i would say this is for just for
me and you
and okay you right in there
one two and three what were some hard
things about today and one two and three
what were some good things about today
and i want him to i want you to begin to
focus on this can happen at bedtime this
can happen at dinner time dinner time is
really great because it's hard to hide
there
no electronics at the dinner table no
headphones no disappearing
and everyone's gonna go on the table and
say here's
here's the bmws what's the best and
worst parts of the day what's the goods
and the bads and there's all kinds of
different words for that but here's what
we want to do i want us to begin to
verbalize in our house
we look for beauty and we find it
even when things are hard
you have to model that dad has to model
that if he's around um brother has to
model that everybody's got to model it
and often that pessimism is absorbed
somewhere and it may be right because
there's no sunshine
months at a time
it may be i don't know is is he getting
that somewhere
um well i mean
i think he lives the same life that
everyone else does in the house i know
you're laughing well just what you said
like well we are very
uh i can sort of people so
i don't know we just do do do do do so i
don't know i don't i don't know if he's
just another way that he doesn't fit in
because i remember when he's little i
was like you know oscar i said his name
sometimes you have to
choose to be happy like it's just like
you it's a choice you just have to be
like i'm not going to let this get me
down and he's like i try to tell myself
to be happy it doesn't work so let's
change the language change the language
because i think that when you tell
somebody and i i've done this too a
bajillion times
you can choose to be happy i don't think
that's true anymore
i do think
you can choose the things to do the
things that help you become happy
so what i mean by that
i don't i can't sit at home and say be
happy idiot because i want right right
but i can get up and go outside and go
for a walk and write in my gratitude
journal and write my grandma a note even
though she passed away several years ago
i can draw my right up my five-year-old
daughter is obsessed with getting
letters from me and it's amazing it's so
great i can write her a letter
i can do those things that i know on the
back end i can
eat well i can go garden for a while
whatever the thing is i can do the
things that i know are gonna pay off but
those are a physiological response i can
go play my guitar i can go do those
things
it's not forcing myself into a set of
feelings
right and so what i would love to see
you all do is to begin to
back away from that language you should
be feeling like this and sometimes you
just got to do these things
even if you don't feel like it because
you will on the back yeah
yeah does that make sense yep yep yep
and we have those conversations too
we do all the time
and remember a 14 year old is going to
not listen to you he's going to watch
you
yes and he's not going to listen to dad
he's going to watch everybody
and in a culture that you guys are in of
do do do
dropping somebody in who feel feel feels
is hard
and so if you model no i feel that and
it's hard and it stinks i'm sorry
and you model and then we go do both and
then that's the gift to him but i do
think it's worth starting with a school
counselor starting with a teacher
and setting up a meeting
and you will get a sense very quickly
this teacher doesn't care about my kid
you'll get a sense very quickly
uh this teacher wants to jump in and
solve this and that's not what you're
asking for
will you just keep an eye out on my kid
and
if we get to a place where
you are reading this
daily journal back and forth and by the
way if he doesn't write in this thing
even if he's being obnoxious and
being a 14 year old i love 14 year olds
they're so great they're hilarious and
obnoxious
and so sarcastic i just love him
and he won't write in it then he loses
privilege i mean this is part of
opting into your home that we all
participate in this we all communicate
with one another and i'm giving you a
new avenue and you owe me a poem or a
picture or a song or a how are you doing
you owe me three things you saw today
that were beautiful you owe me those
things every day it's part of our it's
part of our ongoing dialogue in our home
um
if you see those things beginning to dip
down or heaven forbid you he starts
talking about
i don't think i should be here i don't
want to be here self-harm kind of stuff
then you
you flip on the lights and sound the
alarms
but let's work on the communication
stuff so let's come up with a new way to
communicate with one another and it
could be they'll just write hilarious
poems back and forth or you write
letters to each other back whatever that
looks like
and
let's talk about not forcing not
choosing to feel a certain way but let's
choose to do the things that are going
to lead us to feeling okay
great great great question marie you're
awesome he's lucky to have you
um that little boy won the lottery with
having you as his mama and
don't hesitate if this pervasive
aggressive intentional over and over
call parents
call the school
um take it from somebody who didn't and
i wish i had them i wish i hadn't we'll
be right back on the dr john delonay
show
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relational health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit dream
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com
promo code d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we are back
jack
what's up sarah and banger main you're
not jack i was just trying to rhyme
because i want to be a rapper but i'm
not i just made this whole thing a mess
how are you
okay how are you i'm good what's going
on
well thanks for taking my call i've got
kind of a dilemma
bring it on
my
daughter was
scouted to me by her younger sibling
okay go back and do that again i just
you cut out
um my pre-teen daughter
recently outed to me by her younger
siblings as being bisexual
okay she doesn't want to talk about it
and she has made me promise not to tell
her dad oh okay
yeah so i'm i'm trying to figure out how
do i balance
your water trust
versus being honest with my husband in
our marriage
[Laughter]
what what are you have you ever listened
to this show before
uh many times yes okay so what number
one thank you there's only about 11 of
us left and so i'm grateful
um what do you think
that you should do
um
i i don't know
i've been just kind of talking to her
trying to
trying to convince her to talk to her
dad
because i don't think that he's going to
freak out about it he's very accepting
i want him to be able to help support
her
and
i
i believe in honesty between us so
i i just don't want to do it against her
wishes and have her not trust me
gotcha okay
so
a couple of it's super important moments
here and is she your oldest
yeah awesome so you have a chance to
screw this up and you'll never get it
back okay so you got it
i'm worried about i'm totally kidding
um
totally totally kidding so
but this is a really neat moment in your
family's history especially in your
relationship with her and so
hold two things
in uh one and one hand and one on the
other okay first thing is
you are modeling
what a good marriage looks like
so that's a meta that's something that's
gonna pay dividends down the road and we
all know secrets destroy marriages
yes and
you're modeling how you best love
somebody
who's
going through some sort of anything
and so i think it's really important
that you sit down with her and say i
love you
and
i do not keep
secrets in my marriage
so
what if
i told dad my husband
let's call him bill i'm gonna tell bill
that you came to me with um
a really big thing that i found out
about it and it was big and it's on your
heart and that we are talking about it
together and that you are uncomfortable
talking to him
but one day we'll have that conversation
together
and that's that's a middle ground
letting her know i'm gonna tell him here
is one way we could do it or
i will tell him everything but i'll let
him know that you don't want to talk
about it yet
um and i will let you have that
conversation with with him on your terms
when you're ready and if you can hear my
language there it's a it's gonna happen
it doesn't have to be right now but i'm
not gonna hold secrets from my husband
does that make sense
it does
so there's some discomfort there i get
a how old is she
almost 13. okay
your 13 year old is
doesn't get a vote how about that
right in how your marriage is gonna go
and which things you are aren't gonna
tell it feels like you're violating her
trust you're not
the other side of this is
this is an entry
this is a testing moment for how are you
gonna handle my heart and this you'll
have a hundred of these or a thousand
not a thousand but you'll have a bunch
of these
before y'all's relationship is over
someday right when you're an old old old
200 year old grandma
um
the other hand here is you're holding is
how are you going to handle my heart
when i tell you something hard
and that's when there's less info less
trying to convince less data and more
how are we feeling today tell me what's
on your heart and mind what's going on
that makes sense okay
it does
i think one of the biggest things she's
ever confided in me she's not to people
and honestly
you're cutting out a little bit say that
again so this is the biggest thing she's
ever convided in you
yeah she's not one to confide in people
she thinks to herself okay
you know this being something that now i
have
in my keeping
if i start telling people that
this would be something where she's not
going to confide in me in the future
and i think
so let's look at this a different way
so
you're you're breaking up a little bit
so but i heard it and i want to make
sure that the listener everybody's
hearing this
your daughter doesn't confide in a lot
of people she keeps things very private
and she has mul who knows the the
reasons she's a 13 14 year old
um
young woman
but she keeps things private
in her head the worst case scenario is
that people find out these things
whatever these things happen to be
and then she's ostracized she's mocked
she's told she's dumb her feelings don't
matter all that stuff
a great gift for her can be to find out
a
i know everything about you
and
i still love you
because in her head love is a
performance
love is a tightrope she's trying to walk
about what she feels like she's feeling
whatever pressure she's
receiving from the outside world and
then trying to bring home and then also
perform as your daughter or your
husband's daughter
or as the oldest kid fill in the blank
a gift for her and this is gentle
can be no i hear you
and you don't shock me
i hear you and i love you
i hear you and i want to learn more
about you
because at the end of the day all of us
really want two things
to be fully known
and still loved
and for a kid who keeps things private
who keeps things held to their chest
they are hedging their bets that if you
really knew you wouldn't love me
and so there's a gift there
done in a very gentle way not in a oh
i'm telling him come on in hey bill come
here you're not going to believe this
that's the wrong way right
the right way saying
i don't keep secrets from dad i just
don't
but i also want to honor your trust
and i love you so here's what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna have to let him know that
you and i are having some difficult
challenging deep
um conversations
i can either
tell him for you or be with you i'll
hold your hand while you tell him or
i'm gonna let him know that um you and i
are talking about some hard stuff
and that you're not ready to share it
with him but sometime you will be
willing to share it
and okay give her that choice
and um
she needs to know that she's not in
control of the house she's 13 that's too
much of a burden for a 13 year old to
carry
right even if she says
you swore you would never tell tell her
i shouldn't have done that and i'm sorry
i shouldn't have done that i put too
much on you because you're carrying too
much in mom and dad's job is to help
carry stuff for you because you're 13.
um let her know that you're sorry you
shouldn't have said that if that's what
you did say and by the way parents never
tell your teenage kids that i promise i
won't tell never ever ever ever tell
them that that's an aside that was to
everybody else not to use her
and
do less and i'm not saying you are doing
this this is just every parent whenever
we get faced with these things i don't
know what to say when my kid comes out
and says they're bi and they're 13 or
they're 14 and i don't know what to say
when they say don't tell dad you promise
that i don't know what to say with these
things i don't just say my kid want to
play basketball and they're on the
varsity team and now that you want to
quit
i don't know what to say that my kid
doesn't believe in my church anymore i
don't know what to say with these things
say less
and
sit closer
and say things like tell me
more what are you feeling where is that
in your body what are you nervous about
what are you excited about
and lean more towards
less words and less data
and more connection
okay and then when you get to the can i
instead of playing basketball i really
just want to go
out to the park and smoke weed with my
buddies you can say you don't have to
play basketball but you're not going to
go smoke weed but your buddies right
boundaries come later but right now it's
about connection because my guess is
your daughter's still trying to figure
out who she is and what she is and she's
trying to find out what role she plays
in your house and most importantly she's
trying to find out
will y'all still love me
and most importantly what does love look
like
does it look like cutting me off does it
look look like abandonment does it look
like you're gonna turn your back on me
does it look like you're gonna move out
what does it look like
and saying i love you enough to am i
going to hold the i'm not going to let
you carry this by yourself because
you're 12. you're 13. i love you enough
to let you know i don't keep secrets
from my husband and people who are
married don't keep secrets from one
another
and i love you enough to let you know
this is your story to tell and so when
you're ready
you can be the one to tell that unless
you want me to do it for you
you're going to tell them it doesn't
have to be today
but you and i are going to keep talking
because i know you're working through
some stuff and i know you're thinking
about some things and trying to figure
out who you are like every 13 or 14 year
old on planet earth is
and exhale
[Music]
sarah
she is lucky to have you as her mom
lucky to have you
and by the way you're going to feel a
great burden relieved when you're not
having to try to navigate the 13 year
old's feelings because they can be a lot
and they don't always tell the truth and
by the way neither 20 year old feelings
or 35 year old feelings or 50 year old
feelings or 75 year old feelings our
feelings are important and they lie to
us a lot
thank you so much for that call sarah
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right
i know y'all could not wait for
hemorrhoid time we are here
burns burns like a ring of fire
so if you don't know
uh
facebook bought
instagram several years ago was it 2013
maybe something like that 2014 bought
them for like a billion dollars
facebook realized that they were
becoming the place where old people
complain about everything
they trade preparation h recipes and
scream about politics at one another and
where they thumbs down each other and
they're
i don't know they make signs and quips
and pass along bad science and stupid
stuff
and so they bought instagram where the
kids were flocking to
and as any good company does they do
they do market testing on how their
product is working how it's being
received how the end user is
experiencing their products
and what are some challenges moving
forward what are some um
opportunities moving forward you know a
little swollen swot analysis
and if you've seen in the news facebook
was working on instagrams working on a
product for under 13 year olds
what's an instagram product for kids for
children
then this article in the wall street
journal comes out we'll link to it in
the show notes
the title is by georgia wells jeff
horwitz and deepa
sitharaman
facebook knows instagram is toxic for
teen girls company document show
here's a couple of excerpts
32 percent of teen girls said that when
they felt bad about their bodies
instagram made their them feel worse
this is from internal research that they
did on their own product inside their
company
from i don't know how this thing was
leaked but it was internal research
documents presented to employees
including the executives
comparisons on instagram can change how
young women view and describe themselves
these are internal documents
one of the internal documents said we
make body image issues worse for one in
three teen girls
as they summarize research about teen
girls who experience the issues teens
blame instagram for increases in the
rate of anxiety and depression body
image issues and this reaction was
unprompted and consistent across all
groups among teens who reported suicidal
thoughts
thirteen percent of british users and
six percent of american users trace the
desire to kill themselves to instagram
one internal presentation
slide
showed and this article goes on and on
and on
features that instagram identifies as
most harmful to teens appear to be at
the platform's core
these are not peripheral things
these are core to how instagram works
how the algorithms work how it uses
pictures and pithy little sayings and
how it uh uses
full bodies instead of like tic toc
focuses on faces or on feeling like the
core presentation of instagram is
hurting kids
in august senators richard blumenthal
and marsha blackburn in a letter to mark
zuckerberg called on him to release
facebook's internal research on the
impact of its platforms on young on
youth mental health
in response facebook sent the senators a
six-page letter that didn't include
anything about the company's own studies
instead it said
we are not aware of a consensus among
studies or experts about how much screen
time is too much
totally dodged it in fact when they said
we want to see your research that you
have done on your products on how it's
affecting kids
they said well we don't know of any
studies out there
thanks for the thanks for the inquiry
remember when
cancer
when uh smoking
tobacco producers had all those studies
on cancer and they said oh crap and they
buried them
and as several more companies are coming
to the forefront
um
they're buying their own scientists
they're hiring scientists and then
they're doing their own internal
research not relying on university
labs often
because university labs are publicly
funded
and that means the results both good and
or bad are in the public sphere
and so if i just hire my own scientists
do my own internal data my own internal
research i own all the results which
means i can take the bad ones and put
them in a shredder
that means if i'm creating the next new
diet supplement
and it kills people or gives them rocket
diarrhea or they lose 800 pounds and
cognitive function
but i find one study of the 20 i did
that says oh my name they lost
0.002
200.02 percent body fat when they took
this supplement i can say
research backs that this thing works and
i can take all 19 other studies and put
in the drawer
that's what's happening here
man
some of the researchers jonathan heights
said i asked mark zuckerberg to help us
out as parents
and mark said i'm working on it
here's the thing
i promise you
i promise you
both from my personal experience from
the data the ever-increasing data that
is coming out in study after study after
study after study
that handing kids a smartphone and
saying make good choices
is gonna have dramatic negative effects
what your kids are desperate for is you
and human connection
and friends
not
curated
imaginary worlds that look real and that
make them feel worse about themselves
that make them want to not exist anymore
in the company
i'll say plural the companies that are
creating this
know
they know
and it's just a matter of time and we're
all gonna say oh we knew better
i'm calling on his parents let's do it
differently
let's
be
different
it's my friend nathan
and i we
are always back and forth
be the only one
be the first and only parent in your
little circle that says you know what
we're just taking this crap away from
our kids
they're taking it away
we're gonna make our kids communicate
with real people
they can zoom their friends in the
living room
but they're not gonna be on these
platforms just rolling scrolling
scrolling scrolling scrolling parents
connect with your kids
take the screens away take the apps away
the social media away stop stop stop
you can disagree with me on that i'd
love to hear your disagreements write me
your emails let me know that i'm wrong
and i'm crazy i'd love to hear it
i've not seen one compelling research
study one compelling interaction with a
child who
made me think you know what i'm wrong i
should give my kids all my kids social
media
they're seven they should have tick tock
you're right they are nine they should
be on instagram yeah you know what i
need to get my kids
twitter that's probably a smart idea i
haven't seen one
i haven't seen one
i've seen a bunch of exhausted parents
myself included who are just like you
know what i'm i might i'm whatever i'm
gonna go watch netflix i'm tired do
whatever you're gonna do make good
choices
and parents is not enough anymore
it's not enough anymore let's do right
by our kids
all right hemorrhoids over and to get us
out of this we're going to uh henry's
aren't over
k how are i don't even know how they're
over i know there's some procedures and
stuff
i don't want to talk about that
we are not talking about that
when did this song came out it came out
a long time ago which one is it the
turtles
60s the 60s
a long time ago before there was compact
discs and uh
cd players that is a compact disc eight
tracks tapes
people just sat in a room and played
music together
and the
turtles wrote an incredible song
james hates the song because it's all
about joy and positivity and it's not
really i love this song i know you do
love a song
it's called happy together
this is the antidote to social media
good folks and it goes like this
imagine me and you
i do
i think about you day and night it's
only right to think about the girl you
love so hold her tight so
happy together
if i should call you up invest a dime
and you say you belong to me and ease my
mind imagine how the world could be so
very fine
so happy not scrolling on an app but
so happy together
i can't see me loving nobody but you for
all my life not a lot of uh uh punctual
i mean uh grammar we're not not big on
grammar but they are the turtles um when
you're with me baby the skies will be
blue for all my life i could see
facebook using this in a commercial
actually for sure they are
no more apps this is the dr john delaney
show
[Music]